[Music]
there are countless horror films but
real highlights are rare in this
original we present you all the new
films that you should keep an eye out
for what we can already reveal is that
the spectrum of different films is very
broad from horror comedies to Classic
slashers to hard-hitting science fiction
there's plenty on offer in the upcoming
months at the end of October the iconic
game Five Nights at Freddy's will
finally make its highly anticipated
debut on the big screen the film tells
the story of Mike Schmidt who was hired
as a night guard at a rundown Diner but
soon after starting his job he must fear
for his life as he learns that the
animatronic dolls are possessed by the
souls of dead children according to the
producers they wanted to stay as close
as possible to the video game and wanted
the film adaptation to do it justice
This Promise has already been confirmed
by the first trailers which are bursting
with details and Illusions the fans were
consistently enthusiastic and so we can
assume that the film would become a huge
success in the US the film received a PG
rating which means that also the younger
fans can look forward to watch the movie
soon from October 27th 2023 on we can
finally hit the theaters to find out for
ourselves whether the film really lives
up to its
original the slasher film Thanksgiving
should make sure that the upcoming
Thanksgiving will be remembered in a
special way the Eli Roth directed film
first attracted attention in the form of
a false trailer in Quinton Tarantino and
Robert Rodriguez's double feature
Grindhouse and convinced fans with a
style that orientated heavily on the 80s
at the same time 16 years later the tra
has now been turned into a feature film
which is also supposed to be the start
of a new franchise in the style of
Halloween the fact that Roth has taken
John Carpenter's 1978 classic film as
his model should also be noticeable in
the storyline of the movie it tells the
tale of a small town that is terrorized
by a mass killer once every year at
Thanksgiving in the style of Michael
Myers whether Thanksgiving will match
the quality of its role model we can
check for ourselves on November 17th
2023 the first trailer already promises
a bloody
pleasure with a quiet place day one the
first prequel from the a quiet place
Universe awaits us next year which will
present us with the prehistory of the
first two films it will focus on the
invasion of the aliens who are equipped
with a particularly distinctive sense of
hearing the film was shot in London
among other locations which suggest that
a much more International setting could
be the focus of the action this time the
director will not be John krinski but
Michael sarnoski he was already able to
convinced with the acclaimed drama Pig
starring Nicholas Cage we are also
presented with a completely new cast
this time the leading role will be
played by Academy Award winner Lupita
nongo she'll be joined by jimon hansu
Joseph Quinn and hereditary star Alex
Wolf whether the family around Emily
Blunt's character Evelyn will also make
an appearance remains to be seen however
blunt gave a hint in an interview with
deadline that the prequel will build
some bridges to the other films of
course that could also mean a return or
at least a small appearance of her
character we are curious and look
forward to the theatrical release on
March 8th
2024 6 years have passed since the last
appearance of the alien in Alien
Covenant and although the film was
directed by Grandmaster Ridley Scott it
fell short of many fans expectations
even if the franchise continues to enjoy
great popularity it went awfully quiet
after the release of the last film but
that's over now with the new film that
has the working title alien Romulus we
can finally expect a new spin-off next
year according to initial information it
will stand on its own feet and have no
relation to the previous films
whatsoever the cast of alien Romulus is
getting a lot younger when compared to
the old films the lead role will be
played by Kaylee spany a 24-year-old
American who had her first big role in
Pacific Rim Uprising and was last seen
in the TV series The First Lady also
joining the cast is David Johnson who
some of you may know from the romcom Ry
Lane meanwhile the cast member Archie
Rena became known with his role in the
Netflix series Shadow and Bone just last
year the choice of directors should make
horror fans sit up and take notice
because fed Alvarez will be responsible
for the project on the one hand he
proves with his Thriller don't breathe
that he can create a lot of suspense
with few means on the other hand he also
convinced the audience and critics with
his Ultra brutal remake of Evil Dead
which is in terms of Terror in no way
inferior to the original film we are
confident that Alvarez will have a
positive effect on the quality of the
newest alien Adventure alien Romulus
will be released in cinemas on August
16th
2024 Batman meets Wednesday after more
than 35 years Michael Keaton returns as
Beetle regarding the story of be juice 2
it is already known that the Poltergeist
and Lydia will meet again her daughter
is also expected to play a significant
role in the plot along with Michael
Keaton and wona ryer the currently
biggest name in the cast of Beetlejuice
2 is certainly Jenna Ortega the
20-year-old actress is no newcomer to
the horror genre as she has already been
involved in some of the scream series
Insidious Chapter 2 or t West X also
cast are big stars such as William defo
and Justin thorough by the way beju
seems to have gotten over Lydia in the
meantime as none other than Monica
beluchi will play the wife of the crazy
teas nothing is known about the
involvement of the other two main actors
from part one namely Alec Baldwin and
Gina Davis as an addition Johnny Depp is
expected to appear in a small role the
team behind Beetlejuice 2 sounds more
than promising Tim Burton will once
again be responsible for directing and
will transform a script by Alfred gof
and Miles Miller into the film The Two
authors have already written Wednesday
for Netflix Danny Elfman a longtime
friend of Tim Burton who has composed
the music for several of his films will
once again provide the music the eagerly
awaited Return of the well-known
Poltergeist is scheduled for September
6th
2024 director Robert Edgars will ensure
that an absolute horror icon will rise
from his tomb next year a new film
version of NOS veratu is imminent count
orlock who was portrayed by Max Shrek
and based on briem Stoker's Dracula made
his screen debut in 1922 in FW mnau
silent classic several films starring
that character have been produced over
the last decades one even including
Claus kinsky as the main character now
Robert Edgars will present us his
version the director is considered one
of the Great Horror talents and can
especially score in terms of atmosphere
films like the witch the lighthouse and
the Northman totally speak for
themselves Edgar was already able to win
an impressive cast for his new project
it star Bill Skarsgard will take on the
leading role of count orlock and Lily
Rose Depp Nicholas Holt Aaron Taylor
Johnson and William defo will also
appear on screen this will be defo third
time working with the director Edgar's
Flair for great images and an oppressive
atmosphere should also make NOS Fatu an
eerie experience an exact cinematic
release date has not been announced yet
but we'll keep you posted in any
case director T West celebrated X
Trilogy will come to an end next year
with his stylish retro slasher X the
director returned after a 10-year break
and took the hearts of many horror fans
by store 6 months later the prequel
followed with pearl the two films were
not only popular among critics but also
quite profitable due to their relatively
small production budget as a result when
West announced that a third installment
Maxine would follow in 2024 bringing the
series to a conclusion the sequel
follows the main character Maxine played
by Mia goth who tries to gain a foothold
as an actress in Los Angeles in the
1980s after the events of X in addition
to Mia goth a number of well-known
actresses and actors will be involved in
the project Lily Collins Elizabeth dicki
Kevin Bacon John Carlo ESP pazo and
Michelle migan have already been
confirmed in addition to T West the
successful studio a24 will again be
responsible for the production a24 has
already proven a flare for unusual
horror materials with hereditary the
Witch and Midsummer based on the first
two parts we can firmly assume that
Maxine will also provide plenty of
bloody fun unfortunately an exact
theatrical release date is not known
yet these were some of the horror films
that we are particularly excited about
of course there are other big names in
the queue sequels like Megan 2 smile 2
or the Exorcist deceiver are also on our
watch list which title are you looking
forward to the most let us know in the
[Music]
comments